uso do cromoglicato de sódico oral paraa
estamina alta Qual a sua opinião bem o
cromoglicato de sódio com medicamento
geralmente utilizado para tratar
situações como asma que é bronquite
asmática né que o pessoal chama rinite
alérgica e conjuntivite alérgica e pode
ser utilizado como medicamento
sintomático para pessoas que TM síndrome
de intolerância a estamina sim que que é
estamina para quem não sabe é um
neurotransmissor e também é um mediador
químico ele é mais falado como mediador
químico que desempenha várias funções no
organismo incluindo a regulação do Sono
a regulação da digestão e da resposta
alérgica então níveis Altos de estamina
podem estar associado a condições como a
intolerância a estamina que pode causar
sintomas como o dor de cabeça enxaqueca
problemas de pele tontura problemas
gastrointestinais e reações alérgicas o
cromoglicato de sódico ele vai atuar
como ele é um estabilizador de mastos o
que ele faz ele previne a liberação de
histamina dos ócios e também outros
mediadores químicos que também tem ação
inflamatória mas o cromoglicato ele não
é efica para reduzir níveis Altos de
histamina que já estão presentes no
sistema então se você está lidando com
níveis Altos de stamina é importante
você consultar um médico que entenda
desse assunto para uma avaliação
adequada e um tratamento personalizado
alguns tratamentos naturais integrativos
que podem ser considerados para esse
caso são vamos falar sempre primeiro a
dieta evitar alimentos ciclos em
estamina a dieta baixa estamina que pode
ser a a dieta low fod map ou a dieta
específica baixa estamina aí você vai
evitar especialmente Queijos
envelhecidos vinho peixes azuis e outros
alimentos ricos em stamina e optar por
uma dieta rica em nutrientes em relação
aos suplementos uso de
diaminoxidase a Dal né que é uma enzima
que quebra degrada a estamina é muito
interessante se tomar nas refeições
também antistamínico naturais o caso da
que cetino com a vitamina C e A Ortiga
de oica também são bem interessantes em
termos de estilo de vida é interessante
você manter um estilo de vida saudável
exercícios regulares sem muita
intensidade sono adequado e
gerenciamento do estresse tudo vai
ajudar a reduzir a produção de estamina
é muito importante você est sendo bem
acompanhada por o nutricionista e o
médico entenda desse assunto para que
você possa est acompanhando isso ao
longo do tempo